as we learn more about Avengers endgame
marvel skillful foreshadowing becomes
clearer the MCU has been preparing us
for this grand climax for years already
we just didn't know it from early title
drops ominous plot coos we're cataloging
the way the MCU has been building to its
endgame the phrase dense game has
appeared in the MCU a long before
Avengers in the game the first time was
an aligned spoken by Tony Stark during
Avengers age of Ultron back in 2015 the
line comes up when several of the
Avengers criticized stark for creating
Ultron Thor is so enraged by Tony's
actions that he even picks him up by the
throat before Captain America talks him
down in response
Tony launches into a tirade about how
unprepared they are for a real threat
from an alien enemy with Avengers we can
bust firms do it on the live long David
that up there that's that's a game as it
turns out Stark is more right than
anyone in that moment realizes when
stark uses a phrase end game or
gesturing toward space he's
foreshadowing the showdown with vanos
the more recent reference to endgame
came during Avengers infinity war when
Doctor Strange uses the time stone to
view possible outcomes of the battle
with anos despite seeing millions of
different potential futures strange is
only able to find one where the event
just win once the sorcerer supreme knows
the path to the one future scenario in
which Thanos is defeated his every move
is a calculated decision to bring about
that future this means that when Strange
willingly exchanges the time stone the
Thanos for Starks life in Avengers
infinity war he has a reason for giving
it up when a devastated Tony asks why he
gave in to Thanos strange has a simple
answer we're in the endgame
in other words Avengers endgame has been
a long time coming during the press
conference scene midway through the
first time mana film back in 2008 Tony
Stark mentions how he never got to say
goodbye to his father and then we got to
show him but again I never got to say
goodbye to my father
losing his parents so suddenly at such a
young age after psychological scar that
Tony never truly healed from this trauma
came up directly during Tony's early
scene in Captain America Civil War Tony
creates an entire virtual simulation
with which he can relive the last day he
saw his parents alive in the simulation
Tony's mother urges him to say goodbye
to his father you know
about to happen say something if you
don't you're a credit Toni clearly never
moved on from how he treated his father
the last time he saw him and he's
obviously always wanted a chance to say
goodbye
during his time travel escapades an
endgame Toni finally gets his wish in
Avengers age of Ultron several of the
Avengers attempt to lift Thor's hammer
Mjolnir
even though nearly every hero can't get
it to move the hammer actually shifts
when Steve Rogers tries to lift it the
movement is so subtle that none of the
other event just seemed to notice it but
Thor shoulders thus more detail is why
Thor is the only one in the film and
then the audience isn't surprised when
cap finally will sir hammer against
Thanos and Avengers endgame Thor knew
that Captain America was worthy to lift
me or Nia all along when Steve and Tony
got in each other's face back when the
scepter was influencing the Avengers in
the first film
they had a bitter exchange that
foreshadowed both of their futures the
only thing you really fight for is
yourself you're not the guy to make a
sacrifice play a hero like you you're a
laboratory experiment Rogers everything
special about you team-up bottle both
these assumptions are torn apart during
the events of endgame when they first
meet a cap doesn't believe that Tony has
what it takes to lay his life on the
line for others but in Avengers end game
Tony sacrifices himself to save half of
the life in the entire universe
meanwhile when Steve is able to lift me
or Nia during Avengers endgame
it means the hammer has deemed him
worthy of possessing Thor's power the
fact that Captain America is considered
worthy enough to wield the power of a
god proves that Steve Rogers as a hero
without a Super Soldier Serum toward the
start of Avengers infinity war Tony
mentions a dreamy had superpowers of
walking together in Central Park I
dreamt we had a kid so real we named him
after your eccentric uncle what was his
name Morgan Morgan
although Tony gets the gender wrong in
his dream at this scene for shadows Tony
becoming a father when we see him again
in Avengers endgame
Morgan Stark is actually a character
from the Iron Man comics but it's
neither Peppa's uncle nor her daughter
with Tony
instead Morgan Stark is actually Tony
Stark's cousin who becomes involved in
various supervillain plots but they're
naming Tony Stark's daughter after his
nefarious cousin might seem like a
strange Easter egg it shows how much the
filmmakers still
their characters humble comic-book
beginnings throughout the Iron Man films
pepper is always making sure Tony is
getting enough sleep in Iron Man 2 she
tells him to go to bed after he gets out
of control at his birthday party in Iron
Man 3 Tony Stark's insomnia isn't coming
from an interest in his work or too much
partying it's because he's terrified of
what dangers are lurking in the galaxy
but honey I can't sleep you go to bed I
come down here I do what I know i tinker
even the first Iron Man had a pre-flight
in the original script where pepper is
surprised to see that Tony has been
focused on his armor instead of sleeping
with all of those moments of Tony's and
ability to actually rest Pepper's final
words to Tony when she tells him he can
rest carry even more meaning check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more loop of videos about the MCU
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel ant at the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
you